laurent josée et franck viennent de
parcourir les 18 km entre tournus et
gigny sur saône
après plus de deux semaines de marche
quotidienne à raison de 30 km minimum
par étape les organismes commencent à
puiser dans les réserves
mais ils gardent leur détermination le
froid est mordant surtout aujourd'hui là
on a eu deux jours de clément est là
aujourd'hui c'est un peu plus dur avec
le vent mais on fait avec
il ya un qui nous arrête monsieur marc
on nous disait qu'on était déjà les gens
restent à définir
alors voulu montrer monsieur macron que
des gels et j'en ai même des pères de
familles des gens qu'on vient méfie du
sport sont prêts à traverser toute la
france a rencontré tous les gilet jaune
mais se trouve dans les ombres est
car c'est bien l'enjeu de cette marche
rencontrait les gilet jaune et faire
remonter une revendication par mme
toutes les autres celle du référendum
d'initiative citoyenne
man u n'a plus les jambes pour marcher
alors il conduit le camping-car chargés
de les ravitailler
le citoyen a besoin d'être écoutés et
maintenant nous on a l'impression que
c'est maintenant qu'il faut bouger vers
l'action l'obtient pas maintenant à mon
avis et on rentre se coucher on est
parti pour deux générations d' esclavage
tout bêtement une heure à peine de pause
déjeuner et le trieux reprend la route
le long de la saône
ils s'attendent à être reçus comme des
rois à chalon ce soir surtout les ronds
points on est reçu comme ça me faisait
partie de leur famille et honnêtement
c'est très très très amoureux et alors
que le mouvement semble s'essouffler à
l'échelle nationale franck et ses amis
sont persuadés qu'il va repartir de plus
belle en janvier motivés alors jusqu'au
20 janvier c'est ça jusqu'au 20 et
au-delà
et voilà laurent de viviez franck de
marseille et josé d'arles ont repris
leur route vers chalon sur saône
une dizaine de kilomètres devant eux
demain et ce sera encore une étape en
saône et loire avant de remonter vers
l'yonne puis et paris
leur objectif ils demandent à être reçus
par les députés dès le 21 janvier
prochain et ils remonteront alors toutes
les revendications des gilet jaune
rencontrer sur leur passage